[Musica]
sapete io sono anziano e mangio tanto ci
metto un po' di rap Buonasera
dice ma questo
sono stati tutti quelli bravi colti che
vi hanno raccontato tante storie e
questo ci parla di soffritto Sì mi pare
di soffrire
Perché la vita è una sofferenza e quindi
bisogna soffriggere
Dunque
il titolo che vi ho dato a questo speech
si dice così quelli che parlano bene
Dicono così è l'inversione di feuerbach
voi lo conoscete foirbag
è stato un filosofo di una qualche
importanza fa parte della sinistra
hegeliana ha scritto un sacco di cose lo
ricordano solo per questa frase
l'uomo è ciò che mangia
Siamo ciò che mangiamo e pensate che non
è neanche una frase sua
perché lui la frega la frega o meglio la
mette in campo
facendo la recensione di un libro che si
chiama trattato Popolare
dell'alimentazione l'ha scritto un
signore che a me sta particolarmente
antipatico si chiama Giacomo lo fanno
anche i cittadini italiano Pensate un
po'
perché se ne innamora di amici che lo fa
professore alla Sapienza e Maurizio te è
più grande teorico della tecnologia Noi
siamo a metà dell'Ottocento nella
Rivoluzione Industriale e quindi questa
affermazione
Siamo ciò che mangiamo a che cosa era
diretta era diretta a raccontare al
mondo che gli operai mangiavano male e
che quindi per fargli essere più
produttivi per farli essere più sani più
robusti
bisognava alimentarli meglio e il
pensiero di un fisiologo La cosa strana
è che poi pensava in maniera diversa
perché ferma che è uno che per esempio
ha fatto una gran polemica con le
religioni dicendo ma come fate a dire
che esiste un creatore se noi siamo
parte la natura lasciamo dalla natura e
stiamo tutti dentro la natura ora
Provate a mettere insieme il pensiero di
uno che dice la natura è il mio Dio
e un altro che dice per far funzionare
meglio i telai Bisogna che gli operai
Mangino meglio
Beh non torna no
Ma questa contraddizione
il rapporto al bisogno di cibo
appartiene a tutte le epoche dell'uomo
perché succede
eh per un motivo molto semplice
che chi è padrone la fame è il padrone
del mondo
e dovete capire che in rapporto
all'alimentazione
sono successe cose straordinarie è stata
inventata l'agricoltura ma non
tantissimo tempo fa
22.000 anni fa
è stata
resa necessaria alla migrazione quando
voi sentite i nostri politici che oggi
si arrabbiano per I migranti
ma il mondo è sempre migrato e grazie
alle migrazioni hanno inventato pure il
calcio
il formaggio nasce da un'esigenza
dovevano portarsi dietro da mangiare lo
mettevano dentro gli otri il latte e poi
sull'asino
e
sciabordando questo latte a contatto con
gli enzimi che erano rimasti nell'oltre
che era poi
lo stomaco dell'Agnello diventava
formaggio
e le migrazioni sono nate per questo per
la fame
anche il matrimonio signora Lei mi
guarda ma anche il matrimonio è una
questione di fame
perché i mariti divorziati in
maggioranza passano gli alimenti alle
mogli lo sapete perché
perché quando l'uomo piglia al fuoco non
è che lo sa tanto di produrre
Guardate cominceranno a manipolare il
fuoco più o meno un milione da un
milione e mezzo di anni fa
imparano a riprodurlo 125 mila anni fa
cioè ci hanno messo un po' di tempo a
capire come poteva funzionare E allora
quando ce l'avevano soltanto disponibile
perché sinceriamo incendiava un ramo e
questo fuoco andava conservato
E allora però campavano solo di caccia
e quindi era un Nomadi e ci voleva
qualcuno che lo conservasse sto fuoco e
chi erano le femmine
quando
sentivate dire ai tempi che si faceva
educazione com'era noi si faceva
applicazione tecniche e voi a scuola
facevate educazione
è diventata delle donnine fatte bene
insomma
vi chiamavano L'Angelo del focolare e
per questo motivo
ti fai la bistecca di mammut Ma se a me
non me la riporti perché io sofferma qui
a badastro fuoco come mangio
e nasce il matrimonio come contratto
alimentare lei vada a fuoco lui porta il
Mammut poi si mette la bistecca di
mammut sul fuoco e si mangia tutti dice
la bistecca di mammut no mangiavano
carogne
mangiavano roba putrida
mangiavano quello che trovavano
e sapete che cosa succede a un certo
punto
che scoprono
che con la forza dell'acqua
possono mandare le macine
e fanno la prima polenta
quando a scuola ci diceva quella
rivoluzione è fatta dalla ruota ci
prendevano in giro la prima grande
rivoluzione l'uomo la fa con la polenta
perché quando cominciano a coltivare i
semi a schiacciarli e a farli diventare
farina
lo digeriscono più in fretta
e possono rimanere stanziali
e fermarsi lì c'è un salto di evoluzione
Quando comincia l'agricoltura stimata
dagli altri antropologi di circa il 40%
di capacità cerebrale
allora perché E vieni qua e ci racconti
l'inversione di feuerbach perché
purtroppo stiamo per vivere la prima era
prima in assoluto in cui l'uomo stacca
il cibo dall'agricoltura
voi non ci crederete ma in questo
momento da qualche parte della Silicon
Valley qualcuno pagato da Bill Gates sta
producendo filetti di carne da cellule
staminali
voi non ci crederete Ma qualcuno in
questo momento
in Spagna con i soldi di blackrock i più
importante fondo di investimento
mondiale sta producendo latte
da fermentazioni di cellule
e stanno producendo anche il latte
materno così
voi non ci crederete Ma qualcuno in
questo momento
sempre Dalle parti della Silicon Valley
sta riproducendo da cellule staminali di
cereali il finto grano
e il risultato qual è
che per la prima volta noi staccheremo
il cibo dall'agricoltura e staccando il
cibo dell'Agricoltura voi non ve ne
rendete conto ma cambiamo completamente
il nostro modo di pensare prima uno dei
Valentini speaker li ha spiegato
che ci abbiamo la realtà virtuale ci
abbiamo gli Avatar
ed è chiaro
è che se io immagino una proiezione
dell'essere umano non ho più bisogno di
alimentarlo con qualcosa che abbia un
suo ciclo
lo devo alimentare con qualcosa che sia
presente perché sapete In questo
ragionamento che io vi faccio c'è un
piccolo trucco
e questo scivolo nuovo non è destinato a
tutta l'umanità dice sai lo stanno
facendo perché sono accorti che siamo
troppi la terra non ce la fa e allora
dobbiamo trovare un modo per sta male
no lo stesso Bill Gates Ci ha spiegato è
che la bistecca sintetica non la puoi
dare a uno
della Regione subsahariana perché non ce
l'ha abbastanza dollari per pagarlo e
allora lui continuerà a mangiare ammesso
in un concesso che gli sopravvivano le
vacche
Ma noi che siamo gli evoluti
mangeremo la carne sintetica
O forse non mangeremo più affatto la
carne mangeremo qualcosa
che ci serve da alimento
ora vi do un po' di numeri
sapete quanto vale il business
alimentare nel mondo
9.000 miliardi di dollari
sapete In Italia Quanto spendiamo per
gli integratori alimentari
cioè noi che ci abbiamo le zucchine
pomodori
tempo fa 3 miliardi 800 milioni
sapete Quanto spendiamo per comprare i
cibi senza
7 miliardi
Allora non vi scatta qualcosa che non
torna
non è che hanno inventato
un cibo nuovo
per cambiare l'uomo
in modo che non siamo più ciò che
mangiamo Ma mangiamo ciò che siamo
Eh ma se è così allora ragazzi c'è un
problema
ci sono
un paio di migliaia di anni di pensiero
buttati via
Ecco se immaginate una società fatta di
Avatar di Facebook
di Smart working
non avete bisogno la comunità
e quindi non avete bisogno del cibo
comunitario
Vi basta l'alimento che magari si può
far pagare anche più caro nel cibo
comunitario ci si guadagna di più
se vuoi scorrere l'elenco
delle 100 maggiori società del mondo vi
rendereste conto che la prima che si
occupa di cibo è la che arriva al
ventiquattresimo posto sopra la Nestlè
ci sono tutti i Moles shot cioè tutte le
tecnologie Ma l'errore È fondamentale
qual è
e che l'agricoltura ha sempre avuto
bisogno di tecnologia anzi meglio la
tecnologia ha sempre lavorato per
l'agricoltura pensate che Leonardo da
Vinci quando perfeziona la vita è senza
fine lo fa uno scopo solo per pigliare
dall'arno l'acqua e irrigare il campo
della mamma evitando la fatica di
portare i secchi
Ecco questa è la prima epoca in cui la
tecnologia va contro il cibo Annulla il
cibo
ammazza il cibo
è un'epoca felice io non lo so quello
che so è che
ci sono tanti che si sono chiesti quale
sia il valore culturale del cibo
pensate a un signore che io ho
particolarmente caro che si chiama John
Locke che scrive il saggio
sull'intelletto umano siamo più o meno
alla fine del Seicento in Inghilterra e
Gianluca Nel saggio dell'intelletto
umano dice una cosa molto interessante
che noi conosciamo il mondo attraverso
la percezione sensibile ma non distingue
i sensi cognitivi dei sensi animali no
tutto ci serve a conoscere il mondo
questo signore si chiama Marsilio vicino
e comincia a leggere i classici greci e
nei classici Greci ne trova uno che si
chiama Plotino
e si è molto occupato dell'anima Ve lo
ricordate Ippocrate lo spirito vitale
del soffio nel cuore il sangue
e plutino si occupa dell'anima e
Marsiglia vicino leggendo a un certo
punto arriva
a formulare questa cosa lui scrive la
materia non ha la forza in sé di darsi
forma perché ciò accada È necessario che
la materia incontri l'anima
lo spirito vitale
e quando la materia incontra l'anima
la manifestazione l'incontro è la
bellezza
e il grado della bellezza è la qualità
basta Questa scintilla ideale
perché Rinascimento prenda vita bene Noi
tutto questo lo stiamo cancellando in
nome di che cosa
di quello che chiamiamo
Progresso transizione
Guardate che la Comunità Europea è
arrivata a scrivere il farmaco
in cui sostiene che bisogna produrre il
15/20% di agricoltura in meno per
salvare l'ambiente
è l'idea più colonialista che si possa
immaginare
io salvo il mio ambiente e importo
il cibo che mi serve da popolazioni che
coltivano a costi più bassi dei miei
Ma quale cibo in porto
quello della mia identità
nelle confessioni Sant'Agostino scrive
questa cosa meravigliosa che dovremmo
tenere a mente tutti
scrive
se nessuno me lo chiede Io lo so cos'è
il tempo
Ma se qualcuno me lo chiede Io non so
che rispondere
perché dovrei concludere che ciò che è
adesso è già passato
e ciò che deve venire
è già qua e quindi
se presente passato e futuro sono Uniti
è l'eternità ma c'è solo un ente che è
eterno
E allora la risposta che da
Sant'Agostino è
il tempo
contiene in sé il presente del passato
il presente del presente e presente nel
futuro questa è la transizione buona
e quella che tradisce il passato ma lo
porta dietro l'ottualizza e lo Proietta
nel futuro
questa è la prima epoca in cui nel mio
ristretto
cioè occuparsi di agricoltura di
enogastronomia di economia dei territori
è la prima volta che vedo l'uomo
desideroso di vivere un eterno presente
e nell'eterno presente non c'è posto per
le tagliatelle che sono eredi delle
lagane romane
e nell'eterno presente non c'è posto per
il pane
che è l'evoluzione del pane di farro che
i piceni si scambiavano in segno di
prosperità e nell'eterno presente non
c'è posto per interrogarsi se Nazareno
Strambelli da Crispiero l'uomo che da
una spiga di grano ne fece due Per
sfamare i contadini abbia ancora diritto
di esistere perché se basta un po' di
chimica a sfamare il mondo tutto questo
non serve Ecco la transizione che ci
stiamo immaginando è un po' malata di
questo presentismo ma se vi mettete a
tavola con un piatto di spaghetti
probabilmente avrete un'altra
transizione Grazie
[Applauso]